foreign
[Music]
you don't have to speak the same
language to understand that we're all in
this together divorce is not an option
trust us don't fall
can't even say the age I'm gonna be
dead
we only Build a Better World if we're
doing it together and Gathering
like-minded Partners like California and
Governor Newsom is the way that we make
this better future a reality for
everyone
keeping me up at night
hi good night everybody
[Applause]
me Halloween everybody it is October
31st the last day of October in the year
2022 it is a scary scary day you never
know what could happen on Halloween be
it a zombie showing up to your door or a
Democrat canvasser same thing and you're
eating a lot of chocolate and then
you're not feeling so good about 2 A.M
but you do it every year I want to give
a special shout out to Connor who put
that little short together for us and
the short is posted separately if I'm
not mistaken on our channels if you'd
like to share it elsewhere of course as
always we are live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and blazetv uh subscribe if you
have not and I was going to wait to say
this uh till tomorrow since today is the
last day of the month but I think I
could say it today uh we'll close out
October which is our biggest month
across every platform period like like
we blew away every number so good things
are happening the teams feel and good I
was going to offer you extra guacamole
today but we had Chipotle no we had
Chick-fil-A on Friday we had Chipotle on
Thursday we're going healthy today guys
I'm sorry that's how it's going to be
we're it's going to be candy tonight
anyway uh this is a big show for you I
have a feeling this might end up being
our longest show ever because we are
jam-packed and and the momentum shift is
real I think you guys are really really
seeing it now it's like okay we've
exposed the woke for a long time enough
people have seen it people are sick of
the chopping kids genitals off they have
had it with the racism all the stuff in
schools the crashing of the economy the
crazy War people have just about had it
with all of this stuff and now the
pushback really is here the the numbers
now on these polls are starting to get
crazy right there is looking like it's
going to not just be a red wave but a
red freaking tidal wave basically across
the country and it's exactly what we
need
and don't get overconfident about it but
it's happening there are rallies now
even in New York we're going to show you
like I think this Lee zeldin thing is
real I said it a couple weeks ago and it
sounded completely nuts now a lot of
people are starting to think it's real
the backlash to the woke is here and the
question is if we take power let's say
if we whatever that means right whatever
that means if we get some some uh more
governorships if we get the Senate if we
get the house what does it mean what
when I say we I just mean sane people if
sanity is back what will it look like
and then of course the other piece of
all of this is that this Elon Musk
purchase of Twitter cannot be overstated
this was a long time coming right I've
done a million shows on this and was it
going to happen wasn't it gonna happen
how much was he going to buy it for were
they going to force him to buy it after
they were trying to make sure he
couldn't buy it how many of the accounts
on there are Bots and all of this but
how would this actually affect our
national conversation whether you're on
Twitter or not the taste makers are on
there and something does feel like it's
shifted even only in in the four or so
days since he's taken over at Twitter
and then the weird story of the weekend
if you didn't hear about this and we'll
get into it a bit is that Paul Pelosi
who is Nancy Pelosi's husband I mean
think about it this guy wakes up every
morning has to turn and see the Crypt
Keeper over there uh he uh he was
arrested for uh driving drunk a couple
weeks ago well apparently somebody bust
into their house basically a naked guy
there was a hammer
doesn't make a lot of sense the guy
lived in like a BLM uh genderless house
somewhere in San Francisco everyone's
using it for their own political uh
posturing we're gonna dissect that and
much more on this Halloween real quick
guys let me talk to you about real
estate agents I trust and then we will
get to it uh you know that buying or
selling a home is already one of the
most stressful things you can do and it
can be way worse if you're not working
with the right agent usually our homes
are our biggest investment which of
course is a ton of responsibility and
you need an agent who takes that
seriously which is why I recommend real
estate agents I trust they work with
only the best agents in every Market
they do their homework talking to every
agent before inviting them to join their
Network and here's a big one they only
work with full-time Pros no part-time or
inexperienced agents their team makes
the introduction and then follows you
through the buying or selling process to
make sure that you're satisfied the
agents they work with have long track
records they're the best sellers in
their field and even under these intense
economic conditions with High interest
rates and high inflation real estate
agents I trust has provided their
customers with agents who've overcome
these challenges in the past they're
part of this audience they share your
values and they're almost anywhere you
want to go just go over to
realestateagent side trust.com give them
some basic info they will contact you
make an introduction to a preferred
agent in your town you will move and
live happily ever after Okay so let's
get to it because the internet I just
tweeted this out and I think this is
right if I dare quote myself the
internet is starting to feel fun again
for as miserable as the censorship has
been and the shadow Banning and if you
post this your friends turn on you and
all that something because of this Elon
thing again whether you're on Twitter or
not and if you're not on Twitter God
bless you and don't get on Twitter but
it is the place where the stuff starts
the conversation starts there and then
seems to burst forth into the real world
that's just how it works uh well uh Elon
Musk is now the owner of Twitter he
fired a whole bunch of people we'll get
to some of them in a few minutes but
because he is basically say his basic
premise is this hey we're going to
defend Free Speech as much as possible
that's all he's saying we are going to
try not to police speech all the time uh
he has said we are going to put together
some kind of counsel like a Jedi Council
of a bunch of people from all across the
political Spectrum to talk about what
policy should be this is exactly what a
mature internet would look like and
maybe 20 years now into this social
media adolescence we're at the point
where where we can level up this thing
and mature this thing by the way the
idea of having a few people
honestly and uh proactively discuss some
of the policies is exactly what we're
doing over at Rumble as well so there
there is there are new rails being built
right now in any event
Elon Musk takes over Twitter uh and then
this this wacky Paul Pelosi instance
happens and immediately uh people are
screaming oh it's an alt-right person
that broke into the Pelosi's house some
people are saying it's a lefty like
everyone's using it for their own
political purposes and Elon Musk got
into it so first I want to show you a
tweet by Jimmy Kimmel now Jimmy Kimmel
as you know he is a late night comedian
but he's just part of the machine right
I always say he's one of these guys like
Colbert they just give the machine what
they want they call everybody racist if
you're against them they'll try to
destroy you here's here's Jimmy Kimmel's
tweet to Elon Musk he wrote it has been
interesting over the years to watch you
Blossom from the electric car guy into a
fully formed piece of [ __ ] and then he
retweeted a tweet by Elon Musk now I'll
get to the Elon Musk tweet in just a
moment but since Jimmy Kimmel is calling
people a piece of [ __ ] we went back into
the archives and we found this well
here's Jimmy Kimmel doing blackface Carl
Malone
[Applause]
time at night Paul will look up and Skye
and say what the hell going on up there
the UFO live on other planets falling
home like E.T
come along read on TV about white people
getting deducted by alien sticking all
kind of hell up they but and that's a
damn thing now home alone never seen no
Flying Saucer himself but if he do
that's going to be a spooky time that's
what Home Alone say government got to
step up and give 102 percent to keeping
them little green man off this here
Earth because the day them dude sticks
something up calm alone but that's go
well that ain't gonna be no good time
for nobody especially calm alone but
listen up BT you better stay the hell
back now new net new until next time
just here comment below
that is not just blackface that's full
black body like you are in and committed
to it at that point now that was Jimmy
Kimmel obviously uh whatever that is 15
20 years ago or so on on The Man Show
and I think it's one of the reasons that
he went so woke because he has to atone
for his sins but it's not like we could
find another video of him basically in
blackface also making fun of a very fat
woman would that be possible
foreign
that's why I start every morning with a
Brisk aerobic workout
but I can't do it alone workouts are
easier when you have a partner
my workout partner is my maid Marguerite
Marguerite soft brown stomach protects
my knees and ankles from unnecessary
wear and tear not too much longer means
can't even shut up in Spanish
15 minutes a day is all you need to get
your heart rate up to where Please Mr
foreign
remember ladies strong mind strong body
I'm Oprah Gentry
[Music]
all right a lot of blackface with this
guy also seemingly making fun of the
Latina housekeeper uh so when you're
talking about the piece of [ __ ] Jimmy uh
perhaps a mirror would be in order Elon
Musk responded to that tweet with a uh
just
the point is he doesn't care so now why
am I mentioning all this am I talking to
you about this because it's so important
that Elon Musk got into a fight with
Jimmy Kimmel no that is not the point
the point is the narrative is collapsing
because what is it now I'll show you
what is it that Elon Musk was tweeting
about in the first place that elicited
such a response from Jimmy Kimmel well
it was a response to a Hillary Clinton
Tweet now you'll see how this whole
thing comes together we're weaving it
together for you here's the Hillary
tweet the Republican party and its
mouthpieces now regularly spread hate
and deranged conspiracy theories it is
shocking but not surprising that
violence is the result as as Citizens we
must hold them accountable for their
words and the actions that father leave
that up there for just a second honor
because uh Hillary now we know she does
this right this is exactly what she does
right it was a vast right-wing
conspiracy 25 years ago when Bill
Clinton was sticking a cigar in Monica
Lewinsky while on the phone with Trent
Lott which I always just think is the
funniest part of the whole story
um but they're the ones it's the
Republicans sharing deranged conspiracy
theories that's funny because uh Russia
collusion that wasn't a republican
deranged conspiracy theory uh Brett
Kavanaugh is a serial rapist Kyle
Rittenhouse is a white supremacist uh
Jesse Smollett was hung you know you
guys get it it's it's the left in the
machine that does this in any event she
had no evidence that this guy that
you're looking at there that's the guy
that broke into the Pelosi's home okay
he lives in San Francisco he's a nudist
and apparently was a BLM guy he had BLM
signs in his things he had the gay trans
flag or they ruined the rainbow whatever
the hell that is so it's a little
unclear let's say at best what his
political leanings are but they seem
like they're left but I'm not I'm not
trying to convince you anything I'm just
telling you what is so
Hillary tweets that thing out and then
Elon just responds to it and says
uh there is a tiny possibility there
might be more to this story than meets
the eye and then he referenced a website
there and that's when Kimmel got in on
it the point being that something is
Shifting here in the old days and when I
mean the old days I mean literally last
week if the narrative was out there that
the Republicans are racist and bigots
and conspiracy theorists and all that
there would be almost no way to push
back on them because you would get
censored or Shadow banned or your views
depressed or whatever whatever
algorithmic trick is involved but now
Elon owns Twitter and not only does he
own Twitter so he's allowing people to
say what they want
um but he's also getting involved in it
himself right that may not actually be
the wisest thing like maybe he should be
cooling it off a bit but he's he's
poking the Bear right now and perhaps
the bear needs to be poked uh here's a
headline from The New York Times that I
thought was quite interesting Elon I
want to read the headline before the
Elon retweet of it it's Elon Musk in a
tweet share there's link from site known
to publish false news now of course
first off if they were to uh if Elon
Musk was to share CNN CNN puts fake and
false news up all the time Washington
Post et cetera et cetera but they didn't
like this website so Elon Musk going to
Tweet shares link from site known to
publish false news and then Elon this is
just so perfect it's so perfect this is
fake I did not tweet out a link to the
New York Times so the guy's having fun
with it why again is this important this
is not about Twitter minutia but this is
about we can expose the nonsense through
comedy and an even even playing field
right we have not had an even playing
field we've had a disregulated regulated
playing field where we see things in
reality but then the algorithmic
depression the Bots the trolls all those
things make it seem like what we're
seeing in front of our eyes is not real
that seems to be changing so okay so
what is the deal with this crazy
break-in at Nancy Pelosi's house well I
was trying to find a legit journalist
and there's a very short list of legit
journalists Glenn Greenwald who is a
lefty a guy I've had my differences with
in the past for sure and we've gotten
into it publicly over those differences
I would consider him a legit journalist
despite our political differences he had
a super interesting thread on what
actually went on in this Pelosi break-in
here we go
it's very possible that the instantly
formed media narrative Paul Pelosi's
attacker was a Maga fanatic who broke
into murder Nancy will be proven true
but right now there are so many glaring
doubts and holes in that story that it
just takes common sense to question this
it's genuinely alarming how conditioned
so much of the U.S population is to
equate skepticism toward the
pronouncements of media corporations
pronouncements of media corporations
with mental illness if you don't
instantly accept what Wolf Blitzer and
Andrea Mitchell claimed then you're a
crazy conspiracy theorist it's so
crucial to understand the dynamic
dominating journalism few journalists
have career security imagine you're a
young journalist at a big media
Corporation you know if you ask these
questions Twitter will explode and it'll
ruin your career why wasn't there signs
of forced entry at the Pelosi home who
was the third person who opened the door
for for the police why was Pelosi
holding a hammer and attack only
happened after police arrived where is
Body cam security footage why isn't the
Press asking these questions this
happened often during russiagate I get
texts DMS and emails from younger
journalists inside big media
corporations thanking me for being
skeptical they couldn't one Twitter mob
against them for questioning Dem
narrative see Dasha Burns or Bo now Bode
knows news can be career ending many
journalists see the glaring questions
and evidentiary holes in the Paul Pelosi
narrative but they also know how
important that narrative is to Democrats
right before the midterms so why stick
their heads up provoke a liberal Twitter
mob and be branded that's the climate
police investigating the Paul Pelosi
attack continue to say they do not know
the motive yet liberal thought leaders
like Hillary Clinton and Jimmy Kimmel
have decreed that not only is the motive
known to them but only insane or
malicious people would would question
them okay thank you Glenn Greenwald
because that basically explains that
there is a system of selective pressures
young journalists that would love to
find out what really happened here why
is there no security footage at the
Pelosi house the window that was broken
the glass was on the outside of the
window normally if you punch through a
window the glass would be on the inside
why was Paul Pelosi holding a hammer why
was this guy in his underwear like
there's a lot of weird stuff going on
and on top of the fact
that Paul Pelosi was just arrested for
drunk driving a month ago like the guy's
life is obviously a bit of disorder but
immediately Hillary Clinton this is
right wing crazy people right Jimmy
Kimmel jumps in at Jimmy Kimmel has no
reason to jump in on this except that
he's part of the machine ilhan Omar
immediately these are right-wing you
know blah blah blah it's like they jump
to it because in the past they knew they
could jump to it enough people would
hear what they their conclusion that
they wanted to get to and then by the
time it was disproven it wouldn't matter
anymore right that's why Brett Kavanaugh
turned out not to be a serial rapist
that's why the Jesse smith thing turned
out to be a hoax Kyle Rittenhouse wasn't
a white supremacist Russia collusion
didn't happen very fine people on both
sides in heaven we've been through this
game over and over and over and now
enough of us are realizing what the game
is and then without their algorithmic
trickery they're going to have trouble
holding on that which is why I would say
to everybody buckle up kiddo because
it's gonna get weird because they're
gonna have to be more or crazy so my
look I don't know I don't know was it a
Maga person was it a lefty was it just
some drug addict and who had a complete
crazy political assist view uh you know
set of views or had no political I have
no idea I have no idea but all these
people rushing to tell you the thing
that fits their narrative they're
telling you more about themselves than
about what actually happened but why
would someone want to take out Nancy
Pelosi well uh here's a video this is
this is good there's a little throwback
uh this is Nancy Pelosi's daughter who
does documentaries uh this is her being
asked about her mom a couple years ago
just what are your feelings about this
person who you know quite well becoming
speaker of the house for a second time
she'll cut your head off and you won't
even know you're bleeding that's all you
need to know about her
what uh yes that sounds like a real
Pleasant lady
um anyway that was a little uh throwback
for you but how else will the system
react to this as enough of us wake up
and as the censorship decreases at least
at the moment right because that's
what's happening on Twitter right now
they will return to hate speech they
will return to fake news they will they
will lie how do they lie often well one
way they lie is with very misleading
headlines here's a tweet from Reuters
yesterday hate speech online online
extremism fed Pelosi attack Terror
experts believe think about that
headline for a moment just leave it
right there think about this headline
how within hours within hours of this
Pelosi attack that as I just read that
Glenn Greenwald thread it's very unclear
what happened there the motives how it
all happened why there were no
Securities and uh security cameras Etc
but somehow they've already Terror
experts that talked to Reuters have
already figured out it has something to
do with hate speech and online extremism
which is exactly guys you're not going
to believe it it's exactly what they
would love to have you believe because
the guy they don't like Elon Musk is is
now in charge of Twitter do you see it
it's something it's so up it's so right
there that it's almost like you got to
readjust the eyes to see it because it's
just so freaking obvious it continued it
continued on Twitter and again I'm now
gonna go when I talked about uh Jimmy
Kimmel before when I talk about people
who are part of the machine right so
they don't necessarily know what they're
doing exactly but they're just part of
the machine I would include LeBron James
as part of the machine LeBron James who
in some ways has almost single-handedly
destroyed the NBA uh because people have
had it with the politics and he accuses
everyone being racist all the time he
has no bad words ever to say about China
uh he had a tweet about the Twitter
situation
he said I don't know Elon Musk and to be
honest I could care less who owns
Twitter but I will say that if this is
true I hope his people take this very
seriously because this is scary as [ __ ]
you can or AF so many damn unfit people
saying hate speech is Free Speech this
was a retweet of this guy Philip Lewis
who said Elon musk's Twitter takeover
Sparta surge in the use of the n-word on
the social media platform a social media
research group told the Washington Post
the use of the slur increased by nearly
500 percent blah blah blah okay so
what's interesting here first off LeBron
if you're watching
um there is no such thing as hate speech
the Supreme Court has decided on this
what we have is free speech and then
outside of free speech and the very very
specific limitations around free speech
meaning that you can't uh directly
threaten somebody's life something like
that you can't walk into a theater and
yell fire with the intent to do harm
that's the specific caveat around that
and then we have very very tight laws as
you guys know related to libel and
slander when it's spoken and written uh
but beyond that there's no such thing as
hate speech because one person's hate
speeches another person's Free Speech
you can say mean things about people I
would prefer that people not use the
n-word I would prefer people not hate
people based on the color of their skin
or their gender or sexuality or whatever
but are we going to start jailing these
people now perhaps you would LeBron is a
fan of China so you know he's not a big
fan of freedom in general
also lebronics I couldn't care less not
I could care less that's one of my
biggest pet peeves you guys know that
one about me I can't stand if you could
care less that means you kind of care
but if you couldn't care less you hit
rock bottom of caring you can't care
less that's what you mean that's what
you meant there uh now interestingly uh
this continues because uh we've got
another tweet from Elon and he's quoting
uh the Twitter head of safety here so
this is interesting he responded to
LeBron and he just put the tweet in
there so that's how Elon is in the mix
here uh Joel Roth again he is the head
of safety at Twitter he said nearly all
of these accounts are inauthentic
meaning the ones that were saying the
n-word we've taken action to ban the
users involved in this trolling campaign
and are going to continue working to
address this in the days to come to make
Twitter safe and welcoming for everyone
okay you know the other part of this
that's interesting so first off Twitter
is looking into it so on one hand
everyone's saying Elon Musk is going to
make it the wild west and people are
going to say all these mean things and
the neo-nazis are going to show up in
the white supremacist meanwhile here you
have the head of safety at Twitter being
tweeted by Elon so he's obviously
endorsing it saying hey we're looking
into these accounts we've already found
out this is a coordinated campaign we're
deleting some of these things and again
elon's going to have to figure out what
it is in the Public Square that will be
allowed if Twitter is the Public Square
whether we like it or not in the digital
space it is the Public Square then
they're going to have to figure out some
of these policies but he's trying to
address it by the way the other hilarity
related to all of this because I saw all
of these people
who realize that they're losing the
narrative right now they're freaking out
they're saying they're going to leave
Twitter all of these other things none
of them will leave Twitter because they
won't build new things you know I'm a
guy I built some new things right I I
built locals we merged with Rumble there
there are new Pathways and I would
recommend anyone that's frustrated with
anything in your life any problem that
you have any Vision that you see that is
not uh accomplished and completed the
way you want go build something go build
something it takes work which I know is
that you know left these hate that more
than anything else but go innovate and
go do something new but what's
interesting about all of these people
who are threatening to leave Twitter and
they're so angry about well now people
are going to say all these mean things
on Twitter they're going to say the
n-word and all these other things
Guys these are the same people literally
the same people who call everyone Nazis
people who aren't Nazis it's one of the
worst things to be called has anyone
ever called you a Nazi
but you work for a Nazi you see people
call me a Nazi on Twitter all the time
they call me a homophobe they call me
all these horrible things you know what
you do you just get off Twitter or you
block them or you mute them and life
goes on but we for some reason and maybe
this has to do with some of the stuff
Jordan Peterson's been talking about for
years we have a generation that has
grown up where feelings matter more than
anything else and they're always looking
for someone to solve all of their
problems anyway let's go back to LeBron
for a second because LeBron is very
upset that suddenly because Free Speech
will be defended more on Twitter and
they're not going to stop hate speech
which again is an indefinable term uh
Lebron is very upset well it's not like
LeBron would have spread fake stories
over the years and whipped up some odd
racism himself would it
here's NBC a couple years ago LeBron
James explained his decision late
Wednesday to delete a tweet about the
Fatal police shooting of 16 year old
Micaiah Bryant in Columbus Ohio the Los
Angeles Lakers star tweeted a photo
Wednesday afternoon that appeared to
show the officer who was involved in the
shooting of Bryant with the caption I'm
so damn tired of seeing black people
killed by police I took the Tweet down
because it's being used to create more
hate this isn't about one officer it's
about the entire system and they will
always use our words to create more
racism I am so desperate for more
accountability
backlash with Swift with Senator Tom
Cotton accusing the NBA champion of
inciting violence against a police
officer this is disgraceful and
dangerous he tweeted is the NBA okay
with this is Twitter the body worn
camera of police officer Nick Reardon
recorded how he arrived at a reported
disturbance late Tuesday afternoon
Reardon drew his weapon as the
altercation unfolded the video show code
police have said the video shows someone
trying to stab a person on the ground as
well as a second person so you may
remember this story and I'm only showing
this that everyone has these odd moments
where they suddenly care about truth
even though they've been exposed
to be lying about things over time you
may remember that story where the
officer arrived as this woman with a
Cleaver was about to stab the hell out
of another woman and he shot the woman
with the knife he didn't oh could you
just put down the nut you guys got it
you guys got it the officer actually
saved a black woman's life everyone
should know the officer's name for
saving a black woman's life but when
LeBron thought he could blame that on
the police and he's so damn tired of all
of it well then he was willing to do
that but LeBron he's in over his head I
mean that's another problem with some of
these guys the Jimmy Kimmel types the
LeBron types these people that get into
the system and you're you're a comedian
Jimmy I suppose he's a comedian Jimmy
Kimmel is a comedian LeBron is an
excellent basketball player he is an
excellent basketball player
um but they're in over their head so
they're always talking about things that
they don't understand this is Phoenix
found this this video from like a year
ago here's LeBron this happened a couple
of times he comes out to do press
conferences holding books that he
obviously have not has not read
um so you're loading the autobiography
of Malcolm X along with Alex Haley I
don't know how far you are into the boat
but what's your biggest takeaway so far
um I kind of just started a couple days
ago
but um I've read and a lot of a lot of
notes over the years it's my first time
actually reading this from start to
finish
um
but just a very um
very smart man
very very very smart man
and basically
um
his words in the in the 60s
and uh and what was going on
is actually what's going on today still
it's like kind of hard to watch right
it's painful but the point is like who
how is this happening to this guy like
there are handlers involved there is
someone that kind of tells Jimmy Kimmel
to do that there's someone that tells
LeBron oh you should walk out there to
be photographed with the Malcolm X book
not realizing I suppose that they might
be asked that LeBron might be asked like
hey what's in the book and then he just
sounds ridiculous again this is all
about narrative narrative control and
and really narrative collapse because
that is what's happening here so now if
you want to see another way that the
system is Shifting in real time right
now as you guys know let's say the last
two years during covid if you questioned
anything related to vaccines or
lockdowns or masks or anything you would
and this happened to me many times you'd
either get suspended or or Shadow banned
or whatever or they would just put a
warning on your Tweet and this would
happen on Facebook and Instagram and
elsewhere
um they would just put a warning well
get the facts here or this post is
slightly misleading or bad this person's
freaking me out but now because Elon has
taken over Twitter it's happening to
Democrats yes it happened to the elderly
man pretending to be President Joe Biden
here's a tweet by Joe Biden over the
weekend let me give you the facts and of
course remember guys Joe Biden is not
allowed to hold a phone and he obviously
didn't write any of this but okay in
2020 55 corporations made 40 billion and
they paid zero in federal taxes my
inflation reduction act puts an end to
this uh well uh the fact Checkers jumped
in Twitter now fact checked a Democrat
this is bananas fact check the inflation
reduction act imposed act imposed a
minimum tax on corporations with average
pre-tax earnings greater than 1 billion
out of the 55 corporations the Tweet
references only 14 head earnings greater
than one billion and would be eligible
under Biden's tax law so again guys The
Narrative is flip shipping the Democrats
are used to what do I always say
there is only one privilege in the
United States and that privilege is
Democrat privilege you can get
everything wrong you can bring in all
the wrong policies you can bring in all
the wrong people you can destroy almost
everything and you will move your way up
because of it Gavin Newsom is the great
example of this thing destroys San
Francisco as mayor becomes governor of
California likely will be the Democrat
nominee for president that is Democrat
privilege but now because they lost one
of the main pieces of their
infrastructure Twitter one of their main
misinformation uh pieces in that machine
they're starting to freak out and
Democrats are being fact chained fact
checked so the New York Times uh which
is which is mostly fake news and has
called me I think a Nazi or a racist
certainly or a whole bunch of other mean
things and also I can tell Connor wants
to be clear no one has ever called him a
Nazi he's working for he's Nazi adjacent
okay you are not a Nazi I know your mom
loves the show okay uh
foreign
the New York Times is covering what's
going on from Twitter within uh Twitter
itself Mr musk also appears unlikely to
pay the golden parachutes that the fired
top Executives of Twitter were set to
receive under the merger agreement those
Executives including a parag agrawal the
chief executive had been set to receive
compensation of 20 to 60 million if they
were fired not a bad job if you can get
it but Mr musk terminated that the
executives for cause meaning he did it
with justification which may void that
agreement to people with knowledge of
the matter said so this is this is
really beautiful Elon is cleaning house
over there okay he's getting rid of
everybody they're gonna look at the
algorithms they're going to figure out
what the policies were
hopefully they'll publicly announce some
of the nonsense that was going on over
there but not only that he's getting rid
of the people in charge for cause not
only so that they don't get the 20 to 60
million can you imagine being fired from
a job and they're going to give you 20
to 60 million these golden parachutes
that's nuts just to be clear when I fire
you guys you get nothing you can clear
out your desk and that's it
um so
uh I I'm tried not been nice today
considering you were on the show over
here it's a lot
um the the other person who was fired
not just the CEO was the head of legal
and her name is Vijaya Gotti and you may
remember her she did a very Infamous
appearance on the Joe Rogan podcast a
couple years ago Tim Poole was on there
and Rogan and they were grilling her on
the the asymmetry of their policies how
none of this makes sense they have all
these Bizarro rules uh here is video of
that and I will warn you although the
audio is completely clean and clear uh
mazemore who is a brilliant meme maker
on the internet we play a lot of his
videos he did a little fiddling with the
video on this one enjoy this is what is
being debated whether or not someone is
in fact a woman when they were born a
male I understand why why people would
not agree with the rule but that being
said it is a rule on our platform and
once you're warned about the rule to
repeatedly post the same content is also
going to be a violation of our rules ah
the meme makers you can see why they
want to get rid of the meme makers just
putting someone in them in a clown face
while they're telling their story makes
things funnier and more enjoyable uh
anyway she is the one who in essence was
in charge of not only banning Donald
Trump uh but hiding the hunter Biden's
story so Elon absolutely I mean I'm not
a lawyer and there's obviously going to
be uh you know plenty of lawyers on both
sides on this thing but I think Elon has
a great leg to stand on like this person
was in uh complete negligence of their
job right like dereliction of Duty did
not do what they were supposed to do
actually did things based on politics
and uh their own personal beliefs rather
than what was best for the company which
by the way you can find videos of mine
years and years ago saying that the way
that we were going to turn this thing
around with big Tech was that the the
public the public stakeholders right the
people who own these companies would
have to turn on the boards because if
the boards in essence were due doing
things that were hurting the bottom
dollar that there's definitely that the
board has a fiduciary responsibility to
its shareholders so that's kind of what
happened here in some way right because
Elon basically said I'm going to buy
this thing and make sure now we are
going to do it uh based on what is
profitable what is right what is good I
think that is good anyway Elon is also
he's doing something else he's also
doing what I said to you before that
that after 20 years of social media
everything we need this maturation of
the internet well he's trying his best
to do just that he posted a public
letter to Twitter advertisers it's great
he said dear Twitter advertisers I
wanted to reach out personally to share
my motivation in acquiring Twitter there
has been much speculation about why I
bought Twitter and what I think about
advertising most of it has been wrong
the reason I acquired Twitter is because
it is important to the future of
civilization to have a common digital
Town Square where a wide range of
beliefs can be debated in a healthy
manner without resorting to violence
there is currently great danger that
social media will Splinter into far
right wing and far left-wing Echo
chambers that generate more hate and
divide our society in the Relentless
pursuit of clicks much of traditional
media has fueled and catered to those
polarized extremes as they believe that
is what brings us in the money but in
doing so the opportunity for dialogue is
lost that is why I bought Twitter I
didn't do it because it would be easy I
didn't do it to make more money I did it
to try to help Humanity whom I love and
I do so with humility recognizing that
failure in pursuing this goal despite
our best efforts is a very real
possibility that said Twitter obviously
cannot become a free-for-all hellscape
where anything can be said with no
consequences in addition to hearing to
the laws of the land our platform must
be warm and welcoming to all where you
can choose your desired experience
according to your preferences just as
you can choose for example to see movies
or play video games ranging from all
ages to mature I also believe that
advertising when done right can Delight
entertain and inform you it can show you
a service or product that medical
treatment or medical treatment that you
never knew existed but is right for you
for this to be true it is essential to
show Twitter users advertising that is
as as relevant as possible to their
needs low relevancy ads or spam but
highly relevant ads are actually content
fundamentally Twitter aspires to be the
most respected advertising platform in
the world that strengths sorry that
strengthens your brand and grows your
expertise to everyone who has partnered
with us I thank you let us build
something extraordinary together look I
do not know Elon Musk I hope we cross
paths one day obviously I'm now in the
tech world with locals in Rumble I think
there's a million opportunities there
but that letter right there is exactly
right it is exactly right the tone is
right
the the timing is right and there is a
chance that we can make sure we don't
Splinter off into all of these ways we
do not know how they've manipulated us
when I tell you that my account is
Shadow ban so My Views are depressed or
whatever it is it's not even that that
matters so much but what if the stuff
that's coming into my feed has been
catered a certain way when I don't see
other people's tweets and then I bring
you guys information then I'm pushed out
of my Lane right they have distorted
reality and from what I can tell this
guy is just trying to bring a little bit
of reality back into the playing field
and man we need it because not only
right now are they losing institutional
control so they're freaking out the big
one why do you want institutional
control well the reason you want
institutional control of course is
because you want political control and
the Democrats are about to lose
political control so even though we have
eight days to the election and it's
looking good it's like again just don't
be overconfident because God only knows
what is going to happen in these eight
days and mark my words they will release
violence when they don't get the results
that they want here's Amy Klobuchar on
MSNBC talking to Chuck Todd about Elon
Musk in the Twitter situation I have to
do something about this amplification of
this election denying hate speech that
we see on the internet now that Elon
Musk runs Twitter do you trust him
uh no I do not
so it's interesting she's very concerned
about election denying hate speech now I
already discussed the hate speech
situation what do you mean by hate
speech you mean speech that you do not
like which one person can say about your
speech lady thus we don't have hate
speech laws you should really understand
that as a congresswoman that's one thing
as for election denying uh well uh
Klobuchar are you talking about Hillary
are you talking about Stacy Abrams are
you talking about the Litany of other
Democrats who have claimed that Trump
was illegitimate or that we had this
ridiculous impeachment over
etc etc uh and of course the other part
that's funny about this Elon thing is if
you asked anybody well who controls
Twitter before Elon nobody really knows
nobody cared it was like oh they got the
censorship that they wanted so they
didn't care now this guy comes in says
Hey more speech guys and they're
freaking out why would they also be
freaking out because of the narrative
because of the narrative because once
you have narrative you can gain
political power I would say that AOC in
the squad are the prime uh example of
how once you gain cultural relevance
right that these women are cool and
socialism is cool then they suddenly get
elevated politically and they're on
every channel and even though AOC is
just a congresswoman from a small
District in the Bronx where not many
people voted for her actually she's
elevated into being somehow queen that
we should be listening to all the time
and what does she do when it comes to
everything well she lies and always
tells you how it's all the problem of
white people and Nazis and white
nationalists here she is this weekend
well also really having to acknowledge a
very Central fact that reporting from
the FBI and from and even in terms of
Homeland Security uh Jamie and I sit and
we he is the chair and I'm the vice
chair of the house oversight
subcommittee on civil rights and civil
liberties and we've held hearings on
this and the there is absolutely no
doubt that the data shows that the vast
majority of of incidents of domestic
Terror come from what white nationalism
and that we are really truly facing an
environment of fascism and in the United
States of America this type of
intimidation at the polls brings us to
Jim Crow it brings us back and and
hearkens back to a very unique form of
American apartheid that is not that long
past ago and we have never fully healed
from it and those wounds threaten to rip
right back open if we do not strongly
defend democracy in the United States of
America
three things she says it's what you
could accuse them of awful just awful
she's talking about apartheid she's
talking about voter suppression where
are the videos lady we just played
videos last week of what's going on in
Georgia while Stacey Abrams is claiming
right now that there's voter suppression
they are having the biggest early voting
numbers ever why don't you show me some
of that video of people being
intimidated so that they can't get to
the polling places right why do you
never show that lady you can't come up
with any of that AOC when you talk to
Chris Hayes before the show he didn't
say hey can you throw this video up uh
how come we didn't see any video of mobs
or of black people showing up to polling
places huge groups of black people
showing up going I want to vote I want
to vote but I don't have an ID can you
help me out we never see that either
it's so very very bizarre but what she
keeps saying is that the vast majority
of domestic Terror incidences there you
know in essence white people it's white
nationalists well my God because of the
internet we found video remember some of
this from these last couple years just
cities burning stores being looted look
at all these white nationalists white
nationalists burning down Pep Boys white
nationalists burning down Walmart look
at these white nationalists just Rampage
white nationalists got to get a TV when
I'm a white nationalist I forgot what
color I am look at this white National
yeah burning it down the white
nationalists taking out a whatever that
was there white actually burning down
apartment buildings oh that was the
Target that was the for some reason
talking about that Target really stuck
in my wife yeah it's just gorgeous look
at what they're doing look at in the
name of white nationalism stealing all
of that stuff burning down apartment
buildings yeah this has been going on
two years of this remember this and uh
oh whoops I could see why you'd be
spraying that person with that uh I mean
look at all I mean it goes on and on and
on okay we could you got the point guys
um we had two years of mass violence in
America's biggest cities and it had
nothing to do with white nationalism
okay uh it had nothing well I was about
to say it had nothing to do with fascism
except antifa which purports itself to
be an anti-fascist movement actually is
I would say the the foot soldiers of a
fascist movement through the Democrat
Party uh but let's continue because
the election is not looking good for the
Democrats uh so they have to keep their
constituents in a constant state of fear
so what will happen if they lose well of
course fascism will be on the way it's
very bizarre because Donald Trump who
was also a fascist and a Nazi he's not
president anymore you'd think he would
have held on to power if if that would
have worked but here is msnbc's Anand
garadis uh going on about fascism and
democracy keeping everybody fearful
gotta keep them fearful let's talk about
this week we just had we are ending with
poll Watchers carrying guns and with
Nancy Pelosi's husband being attacked in
his home by a potentially politically
motivated attacker how much trouble are
we in
I mean I think we I have been trying to
suggest to people that this is not I
think as many of us now recognize a
contest between the different tax rates
or or different Health Care uh policy
proposals this is a contest between
part of the country that believes in
continued and expanded liberal democracy
uh effort to pursue a more perfect union
and a part of the country that is now
attracted to the idea of fascism in the
United States and when you see violence
being normalized like this second in
line to the presidency that was is Nancy
Pelosi in her home the guy's attackers
looking for her allegedly we are seeing
a normalization of violence
I love how he throws allegedly in there
at the end because he knows that he just
made up The Narrative to fit his thing
we don't know what this Paul Pelosi per
with a person who attacked Paul Pelosi
and Nancy Pelosi's house we don't know
we have no idea we just don't know yet
and even if it turns out to be a Maga
person it does everything if it turns
out to be a mega person you can blame
everything on anyone who ever speaks
about anything but they are the ones who
have locked you in your house who have
kicked you out of your jobs who use
government power to force corporations
to do things which quite literally is
the definition of fascism but they have
a panel of people who are wrong about
everything but it's too late how would
you get off that ship at this point if
they realize the ship is sinking how do
you well I should tell you some of them
will some of them will magically get off
that's how some people always survive
there is a certain set of political
people who can get everything wrong all
the time and they somehow survive right
like a bill Crystal or a Jennifer Rubin
some of these type of people uh I would
say you could go back to my track my
track record is pretty solid it's not to
say I've never got anything wrong I
thought Trump was going to win the last
election right
I thought Larry Elder honestly had a
chance in California and by the way you
can sometimes fight for things knowing
that you're going uphill and it's not
going to work out but like the basic
belief set I think I've basically gotten
stuff right over the last couple years
these people get everything wrong and
then they get invited back but they are
seeding the ground you remember the
video we showed you last week of Hillary
Clinton saying that there is a
right-wing conspiracy to steal the
election so apparently you're allowed to
talk about stolen elections again
because they're prepping everybody for
this bloodbath that the Democrats are
going to go through well Hillary
Clinton's daughter Chelsea Clinton
nobody should care about Chelsea Clinton
she hasn't done anything interesting
other than be the the daughter of the
clintons but they put her on things all
the time we have to pretend that she's
worth listening to uh she was on The
View and here's noted racist Sunny
Hosten talking about how the Republicans
are going to steal the election your mom
secretary Hillary Clinton uh recently
warned that right-wing extremists
already have a plan to literally steal
the next presidential election I agree
with her on that but when we pressed uh
Senator Ted Cruz who was here on the
show recently I'm sorry I didn't bring a
prop yeah
well when we pressed him uh on the mega
Republicans election denial he did whip
out some sort of prop and he argued that
your mother did the same thing after the
2016 election
because I'm pretty sure that I
remembered that next day I was standing
behind her when she conceded yes and
that she said while she had campaigned
very hard against President Trump uh she
hoped that he would be a president for
all Americans that of course is not what
ultimately happened and so you know I
think that Senator Cruz just might have
a slightly different memory
okay so she's so deeply disingenuous
right there it's incredible she says
already well this is what Hillary said
they already have a plan now where is
the plan how come Hillary didn't be like
hey I printed it out here's the plan
right now they're making fun of Ted Cruz
rubbing props because you may remember
on The View last week Ted Cruz bust out
paper and on the paper he had the
evidence of a gajillion times roughly
that Democrats challenged the election
Now Chelsea is right in one I'll give
the devil is due Chelsea is right that
the day after the election Hillary did
not concede that night if you remember
correctly there's a lot of people that
said she was extremely drunk that night
I don't know if it's true that's just
what I heard what are you gonna do bammy
from YouTube
um but the next morning she did concede
except she then over the course of the
four years of the Trump presidency along
with the major media outlets and big
Tech they all worked to undermine Trump
at every level when she repeatedly said
he was an illegitimate president who
knows I think she said he what was the
line encounter he knows he's not a
legitimate president she called him
legitimate on Twitter and then said he
knows he's not on video a legitimate
president so if you if you do concede
right if you do concede but then you
spend four years
um saying that the guy is not legit is
that truly a concession I get it we had
a transfer of power but you know what we
also had to transfer power when Trump
left right because we've got the elderly
men pretending to be President Joe Biden
right now so the issue is that they know
that their political narrative is
collapsing and and as that control falls
apart
they are going to freak out more and
more here is msnbc's which as you know
is a televised mental institution Donnie
douche and he is uh warning the
Democrats about what's about to happen
and then you see a woman who's raising
four kids on on yeah and you go Nothing
Else Matters to her there's no there's
no argument other than uh you other than
guess what we're going to figure out a
way to make bread more affordable to you
I mean it's just what you know when it's
about survival when it's about these
issues that just they can't live now you
can scare them and say it could get
worse they could take your health care
away I mean that's a strategy to go but
you know if she is representative of a
big part of the populace and she is and
now let's even factor in people who've
seen their IRAs not a woman like that
necessarily but who's in their IRAs go
down by 20-25 it's really tough and I've
come on the show and talked a lot about
that you got to scare people and make it
about the Republicans that are crazy
people but even with the pending crazy
when you can't afford to buy the stuff
that you're able to buy a year or two or
three years ago it's tough tough
sledding I hate hate to be negative many
over here I don't even know what the
hell that means but uh I am really I am
really scared about a bloodbath ten days
from now all right first off if you're
an MSNBC viewer you should listen to
Donny douche because he's got those big
fake glasses and once you have big fake
glasses that means you know what you're
talking about I should have had my fake
glasses for today uh anyway he's warning
them of what is obvious right he doesn't
even really get into the woke stuff but
he's basically saying you guys us the
Democrats demolish the economy people
have freaking had it so now that we are
51 minutes into this program and I think
potentially this will be our longest
show ever now let's talk about the good
stuff because I've given you a lot of
well we started with a lot of good stuff
related to Elon but then it's okay the
Democrats are all going bananas fine so
what really is happening on the ground
so that we can all feel inspired and
want to get out there and vote and want
to help other people vote and make sure
sure that we get this country back
because I really can I really really
believe we're on the precipice of
turning this whole freaking thing around
well in New York Lee zeldin who is a
republican Congressman that not many
people knew about about three weeks ago
okay uh he had a bananas huge rally in
Long Island my home Island uh over the
weekend take a look at this uh
incredible turnout tonight on Long
Island for our get out the vote rally
with Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
thousand strong showed up for our event
on only one day's notice 10 days until
New York elects a new governor
it can't happen soon enough there were
thousands and thousands of people out
there in Long Island Strong Island as we
call it sometimes when we're rolling
down Jericho Turnpike
um where are the rallies for Kathy Hotel
none nobody shows up who's supporting
this woman that locked everybody down
and said she would do it again whoo
right you got unions that support but
those are individual people it's just
what I told you about the the DeSantis
uh Christ debate right from a week ago
where it was like the desantisite had
real people there the other side has
robots they have people who all dress
the same who I love abortion that's what
they're there for there is something
incredible happening in New York there
is a freaking chance why it doesn't it
remind you a little bit actually
although this one didn't quite work out
as we wish as we would have liked uh
before the last presidential election
Trump having all these huge rallies you
feeling all this energy and and then it
didn't work out but it's like where are
the Democrat supporters right now the
polls show it the the rallies show it
there there are people showing up for
the Republicans right now and Ron
DeSantis who decided to get up to New
York to help Liz Eldon out he had a
great little message at that venue
will you have the power to turn the page
you have the power to elect Lee's Eldon
as the next governor of the state of New
York
[Applause]
I'm telling you guys something
incredible is happening in New York I
said it a few weeks ago and I really
think it's happening I have tons of
family and friends they're like people
and these are mostly they're mostly
moderate Democrats they've had it with
the Democrats again there are no rallies
for hochul okay they're not they don't
exist there are people who are
apolitical who are J who are generally
just like New York forget about it
people who have had it with the
Democrats and by the way that is why I
am so proud to be part of what's going
on here why I fled California to come to
the free state of Florida and now do
this show and live my life and expand my
family in this incredible state that is
Ground Zero for Freedom as Ron DeSantis
told Sean Hannity a couple days ago
very low energy product tonight Governor
great to see you
um but this energy shows you and I think
you and I agree on this the Red Wave in
2022 starts in the State of Florida we
are going to launch it wouldn't that be
something if that red wave that starts
here that is looking so freaking strong
right here if we could export that to a
couple States imagine New York flips
imagine Michigan flips imagine Arizona
flips and suddenly we look at the map
and it's like oh Freedom means something
again right like that's how it could be
right that's actually how it could be we
could do it guys it might be happening
and you know how you know you're now you
really know what might be happening even
the New York Times now cannot ignore Lee
zeldin this is today in the New York
Times why a pro-trump conservative might
win the New York governor's race now I
get it they call him pro-trump now he
have he's Trump yeah I think he was sort
of pro-trump he's a republican they're
calling him Pro Trump because they want
to scare their readers into thinking oh
my God at least Elden is mean but the
point is that they're even writing
something that is remotely like oh New
York is up for grabs is absolutely
freaking awesome and speaking of awesome
awesome will be when we just return to
sanity awesome will be when we return to
the Constitution and the Declaration of
Independence and the states operate
honestly and the federal government has
been reduced to the point that it cannot
control every little thing about our
lives and yes that's the way it used to
be there once was a guy who said a whole
bunch of things that I just said he was
even more eloquent than me who was that
guy how about Ronald Reagan now it
doesn't require expropriation or
confiscation of private property or
business to impose socialism on a people
what does it mean whether you hold the
deed to the or the title to your
business or property if the government
holds the power of life and death over
that business or property and such
Machinery already exists the government
can find some charge to bring against
any concern it chooses to prosecute
every businessman has his own tale of
harassment
somewhere a perversion has taken place
our natural unalienable rights are now
considered to be a dispensation of
government and freedom has never been so
fragile so close to slipping from our
grasp as it is at this moment
our Democratic opponents seem unwilling
to debate these issues they want to make
you and I believe that this is a contest
between two men that we're to choose
just between two personalities well what
of this man that they would destroy and
in destroying they would destroy that
which he represents the ideas that you
and I hold dear is he the Brash and
shallow and trigger happy man they say
he is well I've been privileged to know
him when
I knew him long before he ever dreamed
of trying for high office and I can tell
you personally I've never known a man in
my life I believed so incapable of doing
a dishonest or dishonorable
thank you
I really think DeSantis is the next
Reagan I really believe it I think if
you speak clearly and you fight that
fight honestly and you do the right
thing and you go back to those founding
documents and you have an understanding
of what people want within them
that the government should not tell you
what to do that these people who have
encroached on us every which way who
want more of our money who want more of
our kids attention and lives whether it
comes to the the gender stuff or the
race stuff whether they want to lock you
down put you in masks that this is it
you know it's interesting he says
Freedom has never been so fragile as it
is right now well that video is from
about 40 years ago Freedom has never
been so fragile except I I think if he
was to see if Ronald Reagan was still
here to see what these last couple years
have been like he would go holy cow I
didn't realize how much more fragile it
could have gotten but this is the moment
guys this is the moment where we can
reverse it and instead of Freedom being
fragile Freedom can be strong it can be
strong because it's inherently strong
because it's inherently part of all of
us and also don't forget Ronald Reagan
was a former Democrat right I know a
little something about that Journey it's
why I think Dr Oz is actually going to
turn out to be a great Senator because
he's most likely or he was in essence he
was a sort of liberal Democrat most of
his life and now once you go on that
journey and you see you I know what was
and I was part of it and now I know what
is and the the trail that I want to
blaze so Ronald Reagan was loved by
Hollywood he was a Hollywood Democrat
who then had his Awakening and once he
had his Awakening he became probably the
best Communicator for American ideas for
freedom for limited government all of
those things and I think we're getting
pretty damn close to bringing that stuff
back and there are there are plenty of
people that are I would say they're
Hollywood conservatives whether it's
Ronald Reagan whether it's Tucker
Carlson whether it's Ben Shapiro Donald
Trump Andrew Breitbart Adam Carolla like
there is a bunch of people that they're
not the thing that they want to pin all
all Republicans or conservatives as but
they're good people and they have a
chance to save this thing and I think
you're probably included in that thing
right there uh guys since it is
Halloween uh it is me Monday over at the
Reuben report Community I posted a
little Halloween related meme this
morning this Halloween I'm going as a
Democrat when the kids come to my door
I'll take half their candy and give it
to those too lazy to go
trick-or-treating there you go and we
got hundreds of responses in there so if
you want to jump in reubenreport.local
dot com and a couple comments from the
locals Community radically moderate
which makes you a right-wing crazy
person says this year I'm teaching the
kids about socialism gonna leave out a
sign that leave uh gonna leave out a
sign that reads take one leave two for
the next kid yeah it's the same it's the
same idea that's how you'll teach a kid
that's how you teach a kid what's right
and wrong Amy Says I'd like to ban the
words diversity equity and inclusion
well I don't know that we can start
Banning words because we're not them I
know you're kidding but what we can do
is make sure that giant corporations
don't have these departments anymore
right these departments are the ground
zero for what destroys all of these
corporations because if you are whatever
you are whatever you are if you are a
shoe company
if you are a hairspray company if you
are a widget manufacturer your job
should be to sell the best widget
possible not to figure out how many
black people should be in that
department and how many Asian people
should be in this department and once
you bring that into your company you
will destroy your company uh you might
want to take a look at Facebook right
now in meta stock which is down
something like 30 percent and it looks
like Zuckerberg has lost something like
10 billion dollars over the weekend I'm
not saying the whole thing's gonna
freaking crash but he has a he has a
very shaky product and it's not because
we don't want to live in the metaverse
although I think many of us do not but
it's also because the the product is now
is now uh being built by a bunch of
people who weren't the most qualified
people but they had a certain color of
their skin or a certain genital chopped
off or whatever else it might be Margot
says LeBron is one of the biggest
proponents of hate speech what an idiot
I mean I think you could argue that and
that's the point about hate speech if
LeBron runs around calling half of
America racist all the time and lies
about stories and tries to demonize the
hell out of cops uh could that be
considered hate speech I suppose it
could depending on who's in power thus
not having hate speech laws is a good
thing
ladies and gentlemen 62 minutes
you guys want to go downstairs I'll just
keep talking for a while what do you
think over lunch you guys would just sit
quietly I'll just keep talking if you
have not subscribed rumble.com Ruben
report reubenreport.locals.com my full
interview with Andrew Clavin which
people are loving people love the claven
uh it is up across platforms right now
and we leave you oh I should tell people
me and David and the boys are are
skeletons tonight for Halloween we got
skeleton outfits we're going to get out
there and uh and see what happens maybe
we'll post a picture in the local
community uh I leave you with the
elderly man pretending to be president
which will be scarier than anything
you're going to see on this Halloween
see you tomorrow
which side you want on this side all
right